A three judge panel from the D.C
District Federal appeals court
rejecting Donald Trump's appeal
in the January six
election subversion case there.
Unanimous decision
laying waste to his claim
of absolute immunity for crimes
he may have committed while in o
especially crimes to help him st
Unless it is he'd already been i
and convicted by Congress first,
which sounds
outlandish even to say now
absolute criminal immunity,
but was chilling to hear
during oral arguments last month
when Judge Florence Penn
confronted a Trump attorney
with the implications.
Could a president
who ordered SEAL Team Six
to assassinate a political rival
who was not impeached?
Could he be subject
to criminal prosecution
if he were impeached or convicte
So your answer is, is he
and Judge Penn's answer to
that, along with her two colleag
was unanimous and unequivocal,
quoting now from their unsigned
Presidential immunity
against federal indictment
would mean that as the president
the Congress could not legislate
the executive cannot prosecute
and the judiciary could not revi
We cannot accept that the office
of the presidency places
its former
occupants above the law
for all time thereafter.
The court also put the former pr
on an accelerated timeline,
giving him until Monday
to file an emergency
stay with the Supreme Court,
after which the clock
would start running again
on his trial before Judge Tonya
Joining us now is Harvard
Law School professor
Laurence Tribe, constitutional s
Supreme Court
litigator and author, most
recently of To End the Presidenc
The Power of Impeachment.
So, Professor Tribe,
can you just put into further pe
the importance,
the magnitude of this ruling?
Anderson, I think
today's ruling was
historic, to put it mildly.
It's the first time an appellate
has had occasion to consider
the rather extravagant claim
that being president
puts you
above the law,
enables you to commit crimes,
at least when they are within th
perimeter of your office.
But actually,
in Trump's case,
he was making
the even more remarkable claim
that he could commit crimes
regardless of
whether he was doing it
in his official capacity.
All of those arguments that he m
to put himself above
the law were dismembered piece
by piece, methodically
in this historic opinion,
which, as you've indicated, is l
to be studied by law students
for generations,
especially because
there's very little reason for t
Supreme Court to weigh in.
Why do you say that?
Well, the argument is airtight.
It's bullet proof.
It's not in conflict
with the decision of any other c
And it establishes
a principle based on widely
agreed upon ideas
about the separation of powers
and the proposition that crimes
committed
by anyone, including a president
when in office,
especially the crime of trying t
deprive the voters of the abilit
to replace you with someone else
those crimes must result
in trial and either
an acquittal or a conviction.
They can't simply go into
the ashcan of history,
and there's nothing
the Supreme Court of the United
could add to that
if there were a gap
in the reasoning of this opinion
if it left important issues unan
If it was ambiguous,
it was over the top in some way.
If it didn't take seriously
all of Trump's arguments,
then maybe there would be reason
for the Supreme Court to weigh i
Now, the only reason to weigh in
would be delay.
And everyone knows that in this
justice delayed could
well be justice denied.
The ruling also said, and I'm qu
It would be a striking paradox
of the president
who alone is vested
with the constitutional duty
to take care that the laws
be faithfully executed,
where the sole officer capable
of defying those laws with impun
So if the Supreme Court,
you don't think
has any grounds to take up the a
and there's this accelerated dea
for him to appeal, what sort of
I mean,
how soon do you think what happe
Well, what happens
next is that the former presiden
to get his motion for a stay,
accompanied by a petition for su
for review
by the Supreme Court
into the court a week from today
The Supreme Court
then proceeds to deny review
probably within a week or at mos
or three weeks.
If it were to grant review,
that would slow things down,
but not necessarily so much as t
the trial before the election.
But it would slow things down en
to create a real risk
that this case would never come
because if Trump
assumes office
in January of 2025,
the first thing he's going to do
is get
rid of the federal criminal pros
against him
by the court, decides
whether or not to to do a review
Well, the
Supreme Court will
make that decision quite quickly
But there's,
as I say, no reason
to think it would grant review.
Most of the experts
agree with with me
that the odds are better than 50
that the Supreme Court
would just let the remarkably ca
thorough, respectful decision
of this unanimous three judge pa
let it be the last word.
There's no reason for it to revi
If it were, as I said,
to decide to review the case,
it could put it on an accelerate
Either way, we're going to get
an eventual decision in this cas
unless the Supreme Court
basically disgracefully
just lets it drag out.
Now, you know,
there are people
who thought that
the three judge district
and the three judge court of App
was acting unfairly by
letting it drag out just for thi
But I must say, even though I wa
one of those who was impatient
to get the result,
it seems to me
that it would have been
almost humanly impossible
to write
as careful, thorough, decisive
and bulletproof
an opinion as this court did
in less than a month.
It seems to me it did a remarkab
I can't imagine it having done a
If it had rushed to judgment.
The former
president said in reaction
to the ruling that without immun
the presidency would lose its po
and will be, quote, consumed
by the other branches of governm
Does that make any sense to you?
It doesn't
make any sense to me,
and it made no sense to this thr
judge court.
But again,
they dealt with it respectfully.
They said if that were the case,
then we would expect prior presi
to have run amok
and committed all kinds of crime
But because they assumed
they were not immune,
they were more
restrained than this president.
Former presidents
assumed that they could be prose
Gerald Ford
certainly assumed
that Nixon could be prosecuted.
That's why he gave them pardon.
Same thing
in the case of other presidencie
Yeah.
What this court did was basicall
that Donald Trump is announcing
that if he becomes
president again,
he wants the freedom to commit a
that advance his own interests.
Undeterred by the prospect
that he is just citizen Trump
when he leaves
office, he's basically announcin
as this court described it,
announcing an intention
not just to be a dictator,
but to be a criminal in chief.
That's not a very appealing posi
to be taking.
Laurence Tribe, appreciate your
Thank you.
Thank you, Anderson.
Here now
with more reporting on the react
in Trump World Senior's Kaitlan
who anchors the source
at the top of the hour.
The former president already
been fundraising off this.
What are you hearing?
They expected this decision.
They didn't think that
it was going to go in their favo
especially the
how that day went
when the judges were kind of
a bit surrounding every argument
that SEAL Team six,
which didn't go well.
A lot of them would argue privat
that that argument,
the way he handled that,
saying that hypothetically, yeah
that could happen
unless he was impeached
and then convicted by the Senate
didn't go well.
What surprised them was
how they got boxed in by the tim
because that is almost as import
as the substance of this
ruling from these three judges,
including Democrat
and Republican appointees, I sho
is they say that Trump's team
has until next Monday,
not very much time
to respond to the Supreme Court
and filed that emergency request
to basically pause this decision
And if they don't take that, obv
then we could potentially see th
start back up again.
But they're basically saying
you only have a few days.
They're kind of eliminating this
that Trump and his team
have been using all the time
to delay, delay, delay,
make these appeals
that they don't even know
if they'll went on.
But just making them
do they seem confident that
that the Supreme Court
would take up the case on appeal
You know, it's interesting
because I have been talking
to a lot of people
in his orbit about this.
Lawyers, non-lawyers,
previous lawyers alike,
they sounded confident
that the Supreme Court,
before it came out today
would take it up.
It seems to have been a shift
since this has come out.
A question
now that is being raised
of whether or not it is, as Mr.
Trump said,
there are going to be such a sou
ruling that this
he says it's bullet proof.
Yeah. That they look at it.
George Conway
saying it's airtight,
that they look at it and say, we
maybe that's what we would write
or we wouldn't disagree with tha
I think the big question
for Trump's team tonight,
they will definitely appeal
this by Monday.
It's not clear when exactly,
but they have to do it by Monday
What argument
do they make before the Supreme
Because if you read through this
57 page ruling,
they eviscerate every single arg
that his attorney made
in front of the federal appeals